foreign
Georgia and talk to the great Maggie
what's up Maggie
hey
we're nervous Doctor John hey do me a
favor yes I can't believe hey do me a
favor Maggie can you talk directly into
your phone
yes it is a huge phone is that better
that is so good much better yes
I am so nervous I'm sorry if I start
are you guys dude I promise I'm more
nervous than you because I'm not great
at this so you are good you're in good
hands and if I screw something up which
probably will Kelly and Jenna can rescue
the day so it's all good
the original question and then kind of
go into background so my original
question I guess the core question is
um am I doing the right thing by moving
out of my home while my husband is um in
rehab and detox for the second time
um and then kind of a follow leading on
questions then is how do I Rectify that
yes I'm terrified and that's
understandable but um it just doesn't
feel right and I can't Rectify that yes
it's the logical thing to do and likely
the safe thing to do but it feels like
I'm completely abandoning
um my husband in that situation so um
just background me and my husband were
both active duty in the military I'm not
going to go into a specific branch and
what we do but it's they're both pretty
demanding jobs uh Dr John and um
so this has been going on
for a couple of years and this is the
second time in rehab which is why I do
want to protect him and his career and
his identity because he has done a lot
for this country and um
but the first time he went uh he wasn't
completely voluntary but he did a
it was a mental savior kind of thing he
was in a really bad place and
unfortunately he started talking about
um ending his life and we got him there
and we got him help and he's safe now
but uh he has been struggling with
drinking for a long time and um has
an inner escalated to a point again to
where he was mixing medication and
alcohol and there has been Sports of
violence not at me directly just
around me and the final mail in the
coffin I guess was I found
very inappropriate and Unfaithful
messages between him and his ex-wife and
um I I just feel like there's a light
switch that went off and um
yeah I guess I'm just looking for if I'm
doing the right thing am I being soil or
like giving up too early
um I'm just I just feel stuck I don't
know if that makes any sense sir oh it
makes all the sense in the world you
articulated that very well
um
yeah if we were in the same room
together I would stop the conversation
and just ask if I give you a hug for a
second
because I think you probably gave me the
most sanitized version of that story you
possibly could because you're a person
of honor and integrity right
oh yes sir yeah
I'm gonna give you two hard hard truths
okay
that sometimes run a little bit counter
to
um some of your own training
okay
um
hard truth number one
you can't save him
and you have to fully metabolize that
reality
you can call when you need to call and
I'm so proud of you for calling
and you can help with the intake
paperwork and you can be a part of the
treatment process we'll talk a little
bit about that in a second
you can't save him
yeah
and you love this guy and this guy
you've you've seen sides of this guy
that should be put in bronze and put out
in front of buildings across this
country and you've also seen sides of
this guy that are terrifying
Fair
okay sir you can't save him
the second thing is
you must stay safe
and if you are active duty and you have
any sort of combat training when it goes
down
you train for years
to shut off that switch it says go run
and hide and to reprogram yourself with
if I got somebody in the line I'm going
down too
and it doesn't work here
because what happens is you both end up
dead
metaphor metaphorically speaking you got
to stay safe
he again I've
I'm not talking I'm not talking about
physical safety that's part of it
and I
I bet it's escalating on you
and
um and you're smart enough to see it
coming is what I'm saying
but there's also emotional safety
there's relational safety there's
psychological safety there is well do I
have an STD now
there is am I just a sucker is this what
I'm worth kind of safety that start
those little childhood conversations up
like you know that voice that's been
talking to you since you were a little
girl that voice comes back loud and
clear you know I mean all that stuff
that's all wrapped up in safety
and anyone who tries to parse safety
apart is usually a big six foot two 200
pound guy
because safety is a lot more than that
then just did he swing at you or not
the fair
yes sir
so no I think you're doing the right
thing
if your body's telling you we got to get
out of here I want you to honor
the most important radar system you have
overreacting
um
to that situation and specifically you
know I I feel like he cheated on me okay
the message is in conversation that
aside from the physicality and honestly
not having a husband because he
has been so intoxicated or on some kind
of medication
um for so long
um I just could not go
down that that hole
with him as much as I wanted to I just I
can't pull him out of that and you're
absolutely correct but somebody's got to
stay outside the well and at some point
Pull the Rope up
if you're both good on the well you're
both you both drown
yes
yes sir and just that that is I I just
feel like that's cheating as well and
now I keep harping on that one thing but
you know
you don't have to apologize you don't
have to you don't have to you don't have
to confirm the story
you're allowed to feel whatever it is in
the world you want to feel
and I think your heart knows it's
probably more than just text messages
because usually when somebody finds
texts like that they look backwards in a
whole bunch of puzzle pieces fall into
line and it's just this oh my gosh and
you've probably heard me say this on the
show I think the most devastating thing
about those kind of messages finding out
the person you love and let's be honest
[Music]
I usually say this metaphorically you've
been to war
but you've been in the trenches with
this guy through two rehab stands
you've given up career you've given up
sleep you've given up sanity you may
have given up starting a family you get
up a bunch of stuff for this and so to
find this is
it's it's to call it maddening is
undermining it but I think the worst
part of this the betrayals hardcore
the disgust and that feeling I want to
throw up and I can't believe who are you
that stuff's that stuff's devastating
but I think the more devastating thing
is now Maggie doesn't trust Maggie
anymore
because either Maggie knew this was kind
of happening ish maybe sort of and
didn't do anything and Maggie's kind of
a gangster in every other part of her
life or
Maggie missed it all
and Maggie's gotta look in the mirror
and go if we miss this what else have we
missed it's it's unmooring right it's
like it's like the foundation of your
house just evaporates
yes
I don't know what's I don't even know
it's real anymore it's terrifying there
you go
that's safety
okay and you've heard me say this a
million times and it applies here too I
want you to choose guilt over resentment
um do you have dreams of this marriage
circling back up
um
I have told him
he's lined up but I did tell him I
wasn't filing for a divorce that I'm
absolutely willing to go to counseling
but um I I do require uh sobriety and
you know just a chance for us
hopefully
I'm not saying it's not possible but I
just don't know how to even begin to
rebuild that trust like I feel like that
was such a foundational
um thing for a marriage to work that if
he did not hold our marriage in the same
level and view it as something that
needs to be cherished and protected
and he stepped outside of that no matter
how he was feeling isolated because I
truthfully felt just as isolated and
alone this whole time but I I never
would have turned against him I was
doing everything I can to support him
through this and then in the hopes that
we could find each other again and work
through this and um
so no I haven't filed for divorce um or
a legal separation yet I am willing to
go to counseling and work on it if
he does the work as well
okay I I think that sounds beautiful
I always tell everybody to not make
decisions in the fog like this
but I do think you're very wise and if
he was my best friend in the world
or if he was on the phone with me right
now I'd be heartbroken for him he no
chance he wants to be where he is
and I would say hey man she needs to
move out for a while
it's the right thing
there's got to be some some clearance
here
so the smoke and clear we can figure out
what's up and what's down
and so I I would tell anybody that
when it comes you if you're in love with
somebody who struggles with addiction
you gotta choose safety you gotta make
sure you're okay and you're safe
and your whole my friends or I'm not
abandoning somebody that
I've committed to I know that sounds
like a doormat but no it doesn't because
that's I mean that's who you are
yeah
that's who you are
you going to hell to get your friends
out that's who you are
that's why I I want you to hear me say
you can't get him out of this one
it's a suicide mission you can't get him
out
you can be sitting right there at the
edge of the light with your arm extended
as far as your fingers will reach when
he chooses to exit
and sometimes you may find accounting
there's all sorts of none of this none
of this is going to be any sort of
excuse at all zero
but weird things happen in the hearts
and minds of people who struggle with
addiction and it wouldn't surprise me if
he was trying to figure out a way to get
some space between the two of you
because he didn't want to hurt you
anymore he loves you that much
and you're thinking well this was about
the stupidest way you could I know
right
so who knows what happens down the road
but I think you learning to trust Maggie
again is really important
and choose guilt you're going to feel
guilty you're gonna feel and I don't
know what kind of guy he is he may be
saying like yeah I know you've got I
know I know I know I screwed up and or
he may just be laying it on thick I
don't know
um but you're gonna feel guilty that's
just who you are
you don't leave somebody and you feel
like you're leaving
I'd rather you do that
and give this relationship a Fighting
Chance than to just continue to simmer
until suddenly you are a coal of Ash and
you resent the very name of this guy
because I think he comes back I think he
comes back and you'll have some
decisions to make
but you got to make those decisions in
moments of clarity
I hate this for you sister I hate it I
hate it I hate it I hate this for him
I want wholeness and wellness for both
of you
but I'll say this like from the bottom
of my heart I'm proud of you for looking
at Maggie in the mirror and saying
Maggie we are worth keeping safe here
and we're worth trusting our gut
and we got to step out for a minute
sounds wise to me
good for you